[Musique]
il y avait un requin
chagrin qui tournait dans les EAU
profondes dans un lagon du bout du monde
requin chagrin il y avait un requin
chagrin les grands courants du fond des
mer qu' chagrin l'avait déposé un
matin sous un rocher dans des eaux
claires où jamais ne nagent les requins
toi sur le bateau de ton père tu Bronis
nu à ciel ouvert des oiseaux survet tes
seins toi sur le bateau de ton père tu
Bron et nu un corps ouvert au-dessus du
requin
chagrin ce grand voyageur
solitaire un chagrin qui avait perdu son
chemin éta espagnol par sa mère ch et
brésilien par
Rapp alors comme ça tu Bran des nuit à
ciel ouvert oui sur le bateau de ton
père exact les oiseau survolent tes
seins dismoi il était gros le rein
énorme toi sur le bateau de ton père tu
Bron nu
des oiseaux surv tes
seins toi sur le bateau de ton père tu
Bronis nu à corps ouvert audessus du
requin
chagrin l'aventurier du fond des
m sor sa grande gueule hors de
l'eau pour te voir t'envoyer en
l'air la nuit avec un
matelot avit un requin chagrin requin
chagrin qui tournait dans les eaux
profondes dans un lagon du bout du
mondein chagrin il y avait un requin
chagrin il y avait un requin
[Musique]
chin